hello everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host Alan Saucon and today we have
an incredible privilege to be sitting
down with Chester Santos how's it going
great I'm happy to be here thanks for
having me Chester you've been inspiring
me for last over a year it's been
amazing I'm still trying to pick up all
of your skills and try and apply them to
my life and my understanding of how to
keep up with all of this potential power
we have in here so Chester is he's known
as the international man of memory
he's the 2008 US memory champion and he
is the recent author of instant memory
training for success and that books
doing really well yeah it was a
best-seller in the UK and the WH Smith
stores in the UK it was right next to
Harry Potter on the shelves which is
kind of cool to see that I have a new
book coming out actually in May yeah
that will be published by Sterling which
will it's entitled mastering memory nice
it's a good alliteration mastering
memory yeah so yeah Chester's activities
are super relatable and they just teach
us so much about how to become better
and we're gonna dive into those thanks
guys for tuning in if you're gonna you
know this episode's gonna be about
memory about neuroscience about
consciousness about being able to
maximize our brain's capacity we're
gonna ask Chester a couple of our
simulation questions as well
so the I mean that you're traveling now
all the time teaching people about how
to fully encode information in their
brains to access these different ways
that we can encode information to be
able to remember it at a later time yes
yes so I've given presentations now in
more than 30 different countries I
really specialize in the business
applications of memory skills how they
can benefit you by remembering
presentations reducing the amount of
notes or maybe getting to where you'll
eventually use no notes at all
remembering important business related
facts and figures to demonstrate your
expertise to be perceived as more of an
expert
foreign language vocabulary exam
material maybe you'll need to earn some
sort of certification down the
in your career those are the types of
things that I really focus on and
businesses love that because if you can
go in having a much more outlined
understanding in your head instead of on
paper that you have to reference to even
better for the actual interpersonal
relationship and conversation for
example that would have worked really
well on that the Jorn peterson event it
I brought my whole pages of notes onto
the stage and I had things highlighted
but if I had come on fully memorizing
those major points that I wanted to talk
about by coming up with a story what
walk us walk us through that so you go
to the different organizations across
the world 30 countries now it's amazing
and you're teaching them about this
encoding process via things like the
story method walk us down that a bit
yeah I really specialize in annual
corporate meetings and conferences where
they want an entertaining and
educational speaker to come in so you
you're probably familiar with
motivational speakers that they would
have at those types of events so I do a
similar sort of presentation but with
much more of an educational focus so I
will open with naming hundreds of people
in the audience my record is about 215
people in an audience so far I'll just
meet people before it starts have them
stand up cover up their name tag name
name the people so that gets everybody's
attention and then if it's for financial
services types groups because they deal
with a lot of numbers I'll do another
demonstration where they will call out
numbers they'll go onto a screen behind
me and sometimes I'll repeat a hundred
plus digits forwards and backwards from
memory so those demonstrations entertain
the audience get really grabbed their
attention and then the rest of my
presentation is basically you all can do
this as well you can learn the
techniques that I just used to pull this
off and you can apply those techniques
to become more successful in your career
and in your personal life yeah so it's
just mind blowing when you see somebody
go
onto stage after just you know one time
being like hi what's your name oh I'm
Alan oh great nice to meet your Chester
you know and then you have already done
your encoding at that moment when you
meet them and you did that two hundred
and fifteen times so you met people and
then they all stood up in the audience
and you went one by one and gave all
their names and the same thing with the
numbers that they the random digits from
0 to 9 that you put up on the screen so
maybe walk us through that process of
what you do when you when you meet
somebody what how do you activate the
different structures of the brain to
memorize their name ok yeah before I get
into name specifically I'll go into some
general principles that apply to not
only names but really to improving your
ability to remember any type of
information step number one is take
advantage of your visual memory so try
to take whatever it is that you are
trying to commit to memory and turn it
into a picture or series of pictures
something that you can visualize easily
and it's a skill that you can develop
even turning complex types of
information into a series of visuals
we're very good at remembering things
that we see a couple of examples that I
like to say example one a lot of times
we will see someone that we could have
met even years ago maybe years in the
past we met them a lot of times as soon
as we see them right away we remember
their face we know that we've met them
somewhere before but we can't seem to
remember their name right that's a
pretty common experience another
situation that happens to us often let's
say you go to a party one of your
friends accompanies it to this party and
you're both there meeting a lot of new
people two weeks after that party is
over you're talking with your friend
that attended with you and your friend
describes someone to you that you both
met your friend says remember the
attorney that we met at that party a
couple weeks ago he's also a member of
the Tennis Club given just that little
bit of description a lot of times right
away both of you can picture that guy
from the party right you might even
remember exactly what he was wearing
when you met him but a lot of times
neither one of you can remember what the
guys name was right so why do those two
things that I just described in terms of
memory why do they happen to us so often
it's because when we're meeting people
we actually see their face right their
face is recorded into our visual memory
but at no point do we see the name this
the name is something much more abstract
to us right so I teach people to take
names and turn them into concrete
visuals so Chester I could think of
chest yeah you could think of a chest
visualize a chest that might be an idea
and and you know like Mike I would use a
microphone a lot of times yeah but this
also works with names that you've never
heard of before so last year I gave
speeches across Europe and the Middle
East a lot of times it was the first
time I had ever heard the name in my
life but I was still able to open naming
hundreds of people by turning the name
into a series of visuals so if it's not
as simple as something like Mike that
we're familiar with it's a foreign name
you might need to break the name down by
syllable and then just turn it into a
series of images but the point here step
one is visualization is huge yes
step two after you have a visual from
there try to involve as many additional
senses as you can you know because as
you are doing that without realizing it
you are actually activating more and
more areas of your brain and you're
building more and more connections in
your mind to the information so it just
makes it so much easier to retrieve that
information when you need it later so I
start at one point in in in an episode
of PBS's Nova science the episode that I
started was entitled how smart can we
get anybody watching this can can see
that for free the whole thing on the PBS
website maybe check it out at some point
I performed some crazy crazy memory
feats and then I trained David Pogue
who's a tech industry correspondent for
CBS News and also the New York Times I
trained him and ways to improve his
memory on the show and soon he was able
to perform some cool memory feats after
that they had some neuroscientists brain
scientists appear on the show and the
brain scientists neuroscientists
talked about how it was like how did
that work how was I able to pull off
those feats of memory and how could
David Pogue do it with just a little bit
of training and they confirmed that it's
because with these memory techniques
that I've mastered over the years and
that we'll get into a little bit more
detail during this interview we are
actually recruiting extra areas of the
brain so areas of the brain that most
people would never utilize when trying
to commit information to memory with
these techniques you're activating more
of your brain so becomes so much easier
to remember things and part of this is
learning utilize additional senses you
may have at one point seen on a news
program or documentary film a segment on
autistic savants autistic savants often
will have extraordinary memory ability
in one or more areas you've probably
seen savants on TV that are good with
really long strings of numbers an
interesting fact is that the savants
autistic savants are much more likely
statistically to be born with
synesthesia which is an intermingling of
the senses so activation of one sense
will automatically activate one or more
other senses it's a lot so what's
happening is without even trying without
much effort at all they're automatically
using a lot of their brain to encode
certain types of information into their
memory we're absolutely used to just
going with one exactly so part of what I
teach people is to try and activate
manually more and more senses in order
to activate more of your brain and this
again this will apply to names and
anything at all yeah third thing you
want to do from there after you've
you've visualized and you've gotten more
and more senses involved the third thing
to keep in mind is to try to make all of
that that you're experiencing in your
mind crazy unusual extraordinary in some
way exactly yeah because there is this
psychological aspect to human memory we
all tend to remember things
catch us by surprise that are really
strange unusual you know very
extraordinary in some way right if
during this interview right now yeah if
right now some elephants crashed into
this room started spraying water on all
over us right if that actually happened
right now or you know people watching
this you know online if wherever they're
at
if elephants just crashed into the room
out of nowhere great news yes great
water on them that would stick in your
memory probably for the rest of your
life that crazy unbelievable random
occurrence right it might be stuck in
your head forever without you even
trying to commit that into memory right
and although actually that process to
this day is still not fully understood
how sometimes in one instant something
will go straight into long-term memory
whereas other times even with a lot of
effort we have trouble getting things in
all our long-term memory although it
isn't fully understood we do realize
that there is this psychological aspect
of human memory there is this aspect of
how our mind works and we can actually
harness that we can take advantage of
that aspect to our memory and we can
apply to things that would be useful for
us to remember facts and figures
presentations foreign language
vocabulary and so on right now when you
are able with practice to put all of
those three things together
visualizing getting more and more senses
involved after that and you make it all
crazy unusual extraordinary you're gonna
find that all of a sudden wow it is just
so easy to remember things yeah we can
now try that exercise that I like to do
if you if you wanted to want to know one
thing along that way is that I think
part of the reason why memories go
straight to long term sometime is
because they are in the point zero one
percent of the most profound things
yeah you've ever experienced and yeah
that's why they get encoded that quickly
potentially yeah but and then I wanted
to say visualization some like will do a
relatable example here but this this I
really want this to be remembered and
practiced visualization attached some
visual and then attach other senses like
smell or taste or touch attach more
senses and then make it you you taught
me this too is that you told me you
taught me to make things gigantic make
them massive or to make them yeah
thousands of them and that will really
again it'll be so unusual that'll stick
in your head yeah so those are some ways
as to how this can be made to be crazy
unusual extraordinary maybe it's much
you know bigger than you would expect
something to be or there's thousands
yeah those are some ways that you can
make this the stuff that you're
experiencing crazy unusual yeah yeah
yeah so let's we go through there yeah
so there's an exercise that I that I
like to go through
it's just with some random words so that
in just a few minutes you can right away
work with these sorts of techniques and
get a sense for the power in them I like
to have audiences try to commit to
memory the following random list the
words so you guys want to try to yeah
they can try yeah you guys to try and
commit this list of words to memory he's
gonna give you a list of words and then
he's gonna run through a story for you
to be able to remember them and then
you're gonna remember this long list of
words from memory after just two minutes
of hearing the story you want to give it
a go
all right let's do it okay okay yeah
yeah sure come in
okay you can do it from over here yeah
yeah do from behind over here all right
okay so we have a volunteer back there
that is not in on this but okay we okay
we have two volunteers from in the
studio here now talk to attempt this so
the random list of words is going to be
monkey iron rope kite house paper shoe
worm envelope pencil river rock tree
cheese and dollar that's the random list
of words now normally when I recite that
to audiences people in the audience are
looking at me as if come on there's no
I'm gonna be able to remember that not
unless you give me a lot of time to do
it but in fact you are going to know
those words forwards and backwards with
just about two minutes of study time
that's it
and believe it or not without any
further review even next week you will
still know all of the words forwards and
backwards they're just going to be
locked in your memory how you will do
this the whole key here is to rather
than approach this as a difficult and
boring memory exercise try to come at it
more as just a fun exercise and using
creativity and imagination right so that
shifting your approach is gonna make a
huge difference in your ability to
remember right so just have fun with
this and visualize what I described to
you all right so the first word was
monkey so I just want you to visualize a
monkey right to see this monkey it is
dancing around it is making monkey
noises whatever a monkey would sound
like I'm working on the monkey
impression the point here is to see and
hear the monkey all right the monkey now
picks up a gigantic iron because that
was the second word all right so just
see this monkey dancing around this
gigantic iron it this is just like a
movie or cartoon playing in your head
alright the iron starts to fall but a
rope attaches itself to the iron maybe
even feel it maybe it feel sort of rough
alright really interact with it you look
up the rope and you see that the other
end of the rope is attached to a kite
the kites flying around in the air you
reach up and try and touch it maybe it's
just out of your reach the kite the kite
now crashes into a house really see it
smashed into this house house was the
next word alright you notice that this
how
is completely covered in paper for some
reason it's completely covered in paper
picture that a shoe appears magically
out of nowhere it starts to walk all
over the paper maybe it's messing up the
paper just see that shoe okay
the shoe smells pretty badly so you
decide to investigate and see why you
find a little worm crawling around
inside of that shoe really see the
smelly worm the worm now jumps out of
the shoe and into an envelope maybe it's
going to mail itself or something I
don't know envelope was next picture
that just see it as best you can a
pencil appears that a thin air starts to
write very quickly on the envelope
really see that pencil the pencil now
jumps into a river there's a huge splash
just see that river was next
you notice the rivers crashing into a
giant rock all right picture that the
rock flies out of the river now and into
a tree it crashes into this tree you
notice that this tree is growing cheese
you probably haven't seen a tree like
that it's growing cheese and out of each
piece of cheese shoots $1 $1 shoots out
of the cheese last word was dollar I'm
gonna very quickly go through this again
and your job is to replay through this
little story so we started out with a
monkey the monkey was dancing around
with an iron
what attached it was a rope the other
end of the rope was attached to what a
kite the kite then crashed into a house
what was it covered in paper
what walked on a shoe something was
crawling the chute was a worm the worm
jumped into what an envelope what wrote
on it a pencil pencil jumped into what
it was a river what did the river crash
into a rock the rock flew into what a
tree what was it growing cheese what
shot out a dollar so now it should be
incredibly easy to recite the entire
random list of words by just going
through that story in your mind and
recalling each major object that you
encounter so go ahead and try to recite
those for us
or work yeah it went into it the worm
went into an envelope pens old and the
river yeah then the rock and the tree to
the cheese and dollar yep nice work guys
nice work would one of you brave
volunteers like to go backwards try it
out backwards it would be Dollar Tree
pencil envelope yeah house no no shoo
yeah paper paper
Oh paper house yep and then it goes kite
rope you got it great job awesome so
awesome great work there so that right
there it's called the story method
alright it's just one of many techniques
that memory champions like myself used
to pull off these feats of memory so
over the years I've been on a lot of
different TV shows performing memory
feeds Science Channel Discovery Channel
I'm about to be on CBS News Sunday
morning coming up here in March I
trained one of my CEO clients for the
show and also Nancy Giles from that show
CBS News Sunday morning the popular
national morning show there's nothing
different about my brain compared to
everyone else's I've just learned these
techniques that are very powerful and
effective again anybody can learn to do
this with just the right techniques and
a little bit of practice training you
can do so much more with your memory
than you currently are able to and
really this can give you a huge
advantage just can set you far apart
from other professionals you can really
help you out in your career and in your
personal life I tell people you know and
preparing with and preparing for
meetings with clients or potential
clients when you spend just a little bit
of time memorizing 10 key advantages
that you can offer 10 things about your
competitors while you're better than
them while your service is better that
little bit of preparation that little
bit of implementation of memory skills
really goes a long way and people are
much more impressed with you impressed
with you and also I like to say the
bottom line is whether or not it is
truly the case it doesn't matter this is
up for debate maybe you'll have some
neuroscientists in here that will talk
about it at some point intelligence we
don't know exactly if memory is related
to intelligence but what we do know is
that the perception is that someone with
the razor-sharp memory we perceive them
to be intelligent right after meeting
with them if they seem to know
everything
yeah we're really impressed we perceived
them to be intelligent as well as the
most of an expert in their particular
field and those are the people that I'm
going to hire those are the people that
I would refer to my clients to my
friends I've been a one-man business now
for about 10 years an entrepreneur for
10 years now and I've had to hire
attorneys you know PR people marketing
people web developers and when I meet
with someone I'm going to potentially
hire I might be on the extreme end
because of what I do but you know if
someone is always answering my questions
with you know I've done some work with
that but I've got a reefa miliar eyes
myself let me do a little research I'll
get back to you I will probably never
hire that person the ones that I'm gonna
go out of my way to hire are the people
when I meet with them I my impression is
wow they seem to know everything that
that's really the expert you know so
memory skills can really help you with
that
the visualization is so important that
was the story method again there were so
many visuals there were so many gigantic
things there was there was the touching
of the rope there was the smelling of
the shoe there were all of these senses
that were incorporated into that story
method and then especially for science
so I am a science communicator so I am
learning as much as I can a breadth of
different knowledge of myriad they're
all over the place across Sciences and
one of the ways that I definitely tap
into all these different Sciences I
figure out how they're interconnected
and then I make stories out of them and
they're visualizations that I get yeah
things like understanding the cosmos all
the way down to understanding molecules
in DNA in the human right in-between and
then that whole visualization enables me
to remember that forever it's so yeah so
you hit on something that I also cover
in my presentation sometimes and that is
that with this type of memory training
you will actually develop your
visualization ability you'll be able to
create the images in your mind more
quickly see the imagery more clearly and
many studies have shown as you described
that visualization ability is linked to
more than
it's actually linked to overall
intelligence because it helps to improve
your understanding yes when you can take
complex information and turn it into a
simple series of things you can
visualize it really improves your
understanding so visualization is an
important skill that is beneficial and
you will develop it with this sort of
training yeah and I remember this
example as well I really think we need
to hone in on visualization because I
feel like it's the most simple one for
people to get but you can guide and
decide on if that's the case but this
one example that you give in your talks
that I think is so interesting is
throwing up you're in your living room
and then Trump and Clinton show up
behind podiums and you're not asking any
questions editing back and then you
activate all the senses yeah through
this conversation because all of a
sudden they're throwing pies at each
other that's absurd yeah and then you're
visualizing that and then you see that
you're smelling the the pies and then
you go and you touch the pie and you
taste the pie off their face that's a
whole beautiful way of activating all
the senses and again you can't forget
that experience yeah so I like to use
that depending on the presentation
depending on whether or not I have
enough time to put that in there but I
like to use that to warm up people's
visualization ability and to get them
working with these principles right away
at that crazy episode with a
presidential debate it turns into a pie
fight yeah yeah I love that one so what
are okay let's walk through maybe
everyone is doing something in their job
every day so let's walk through
something that let's make this relatable
let's say that I'm going into work and I
need to remember a couple of things and
let's say the couple things I need to
remember are I need to I need to email a
potential new client I need to have a
conversation with my boss about a raise
I need to remember to take out the trash
tonight when I get home and I need to
make sure to get some spinach on the way
home as well so right there we have four
items we have yeah yep so we have
negotiating with the boss we have
getting a new business deal or a new
client
we have getting spinach on the way home
and then trash' at night yeah so how
would you walk us through something that
would you don't even need to write it
down in know like walk us through yeah
so you know emails the first thing you
had mentioned right so you might just
imagine like an that envelope symbol for
the the email with the envelope open
yeah I mean for something like that it's
very easy to just use the story method
yeah so you know coming out of that
envelope is a bunch of money because you
want to you know ask for a raise right
and then you know the money however is
falling into a trash can because you
need to remember to take out the trash
and then spin in just shooting out of
the trash can because you need to
remember to get spinach at the grocery
store so you can use a to-do lists are
very very very simple application of
this a good one but beyond just
remembering things like that there is
another benefit to all this and that is
that by you can go ahead and still write
down your to-do list but I would also
commit it to memory and rely on your
memory first if your memory then fails
you go to the to-do list because what
this getting into this habit it forces
you to exercise your memory on a daily
basis and the more you exercise your
memory in general the better your memory
is going to get even independent of
using the memory techniques because
you're you're exercising that process of
encoding things into memory and
retrieving them right the brain is very
trainable the more you force your brain
to perform a particular function over
and over again the more it signals to
your brain that that's something
important for you to be able to do so
your brain makes itself better at doing
it right the opposite is also true the
more you don't have your brain perform
something so if you're always writing
things down if you're always entering
things and electronic devices what
you're telling your brain is you know
what at this point in my life it's no
longer important for me to be able to
remember things so it makes sense that
you are going to start to lose that
ability over time right when you think
about it when we're younger we're always
using our memory or
by engaging in schooling we're learning
throughout all of our schooling years
we're learning tons of information from
a wide variety of areas you're being
tested on your recall for quizzes exams
to write papers they say when you first
start a new job you have to learn a lot
of new things and recall them then to
perform your job properly but then for
most of us we enter this twenty thirty
plus year period where for the most part
things have just become a routine right
yeah you're just doing the same types of
things day in and day out you're not
really engaging your memory is much also
when you think about it when you are
younger a lot is new to you when you're
younger right so your brain is
constantly being stimulated all the time
in so many different ways but we all
reach a certain point in our lives where
our brain really is not being not that
much as new to us right so where our
brains are not as stimulated in general
later in our lives as they were early in
our lives we're really a lot was new to
us all the time right so that what I
talk about is the positive aspect of
that is if you actually make it a point
to exercise your memory and work it out
throughout your lifetime you can keep it
strong and really improve it at any age
so some people don't believe that
they're just stuck on this idea that
someone that's younger and aged is gonna
have a better memory than someone older
and age but you know I have 10 years
experience now teaching memory seminars
around the world I can tell you that
I've seen so many people believe it or
not in their 60s and 70s completely
outperform working professionals in
their 20s and 30s in terms of memory
tasks and I've seen people in their 20s
where already their memory is not as
good as you would think it is and it's
more about who is really engaging their
brain who's exercising their memory
exercising their brain really in general
those people in my opinion have a much
better chance of being you know staying
sharp or even later in their years yeah
you said a couple things there that I
really like the in the early education
system I never remember being trained to
use other senses to be able to practice
encoding information so that could be
something interesting to bring two kids
at younger ages and then also
I thought this was really important is
that when I take notes I'm already
telling myself that no I'm not gonna
practice memorizing this I'm gonna just
put it in notes I need to be very aware
of that I need to actually practice like
maybe walk us through I know a lot of
people take notes on life you go and
watch a video you write down some really
interesting things that you learned
maybe again there's a better way to do
that maybe you go back through that note
and then you create a story about and
activate different visual parts of your
mind to remember that and then you you
know then you put the note away and you
recall those maybe five or seven really
interesting things about what you just
watched and learned yeah so again I I
totally think it's fine to take notes as
long as you are not just relying on the
notes alone so I encourage people to try
to commit a lot of that information to
memory and use your memory first if your
memory then fails you go ahead and use
the notes again the brain is very
trainable so the more you use your
memory the better it's going to get in
general one example this was on a
science show they showed a segment where
a guy was in an unfortunate accident and
a pole went through a certain part of
his brain so he completely lost the
ability to perform certain functions but
with rehabilitation other parts of the
brain the brain completely rewired
itself so other parts of the brain took
over and he regained the ability to
perform some of those functions because
the brain rewired itself the brain is
incredibly trainable so again the more
you force your brain to do something
over and over again it tells your brain
that's important for you to be able to
do so your brain will make itself better
at doing it but the opposite is also
true
yeah so you think you're nailing it
again you're like write it down have
notes you can do that but commit it to
memory of memory practice that don't
just shut off your brain don't just shut
off your memory you and rely on all
these devices there have been some
incidents that have made the news where
maybe I shouldn't name any
because I don't want to get in trouble
for like you know calling people out on
this but there's been incidents where
famous people have been you know on TV
having to give some sort of presentation
the teleprompter malfunctions yeah
correct and they just seem like a
buffoon yeah right because they should
know two or three things about this
topic they're talking on but yeah at
least they can't say anything and the
interview has to end right then and
there yeah I don't want to say who but
yeah and then so this is this is um
ties me back to understanding science
again or understanding just even the
general world around us because I've
been referring to this so many times now
in it just encoded into my mind just
really recently in the scene Talib's
been talking about this lyndie effect
and it's just simply put it's like this
Cup or the wheel these things have been
around so long thousands of years the
likelihood that the wheeler the cup is
gonna be around thousands of more years
is very high versus something like maybe
snapchat or an app that was just
developed last year it's probably only
gonna be around another a year it's only
been around a year so that whole idea
again I'm making these visuals of
literally seeing people make wheels and
seeing people make the original yeah ups
that were used and yeah that is that is
so amazingly helping me remember that I
and that's the thing is I feel like I
need to start practicing at for a lot of
the really important things that I learn
I need to start visualizing what I'm
writing down in my note and then trying
to recall that over and over again and
using things like gigantis ism or
thousands of them or whatever these
training methods are maybe I smell
something or touch it so yeah so there
there are a lot of other techniques that
I cover on top of the story method I
have an online course more than six
hours of interactive training but we're
hitting on you know some of the basic
principles here in this short interview
and even yeah just putting forth an
effort to visualize more will improve
your attention so I ask people to do
that when they're
so while you're reading try to see what
you're reading almost like a movie or
something playing in your head it is
really going to improve your attention
of what what you're reading so you're
ready yeah doing that so you will retain
more by by even just implementing the
simple idea of visualization exact
there's a lot of other things you can do
as well I think you're also nailing it
there too while you're reading an
article a web post whatever you're
reading book just visualize along the
way it also makes it more interesting
doesn't it when you get to use your
imagination absolutely yeah so for
students I always point out that using
these sorts of memory techniques it is a
much more fun and interesting way to go
about committing things to memory that
would otherwise be very boring to commit
that to memory but yet you're gonna need
to know it for the exam right so using
these techniques yes as it's more fun
and interesting for sure yeah what are
we okay so we have we have some more
time I want to ask about
I mean Chester's done some crazy things
you memorized a stack of 52 playing
cards in 90 seconds yeah one point I was
able to do it in a little bit less than
90 seconds when I was really training a
lot to win the US memory championship
again the same principles apply there's
another technique that I would use on
top of the the main principles and that
is something called the journey method
people have probably seen this even in
you know on TV shows like I've heard in
that show Sherlock that Sherlock Holmes
uses a memory palace to commit things to
memory so that's what a the journey
method basically is so this idea
originated with the ancient Greeks the
technique was known as the method of lo
sy l o CI meaning location the Roman
orders used it to give speeches hours in
length from memory without any notes so
the famous order cicero used this
technique so roman room method is
another name for journey method and also
memory palace people may have heard
the technique referred to as memory
palaces what this involves is using
locations from your environment that
you're very familiar with and you will
just place imagery that reminds you of
what you want to remember along these
locations from your environment like
your living room or bedroom out exactly
because we are are our spatial memory is
also very good so we can remember you
know you can easily pull up in your mind
where is your TV think about what's
close to that maybe it's the coffee
table close by is the couch it's so easy
for us to pull that up in our memory
right places that we're familiar with
objects around the room the ordering of
those object that's all it takes no
effort for us to do that so you can take
advantage of that and place images on
the TV on the coffee table on the couch
that remind you of this much more
abstract type of information like Obon
the TV would be the little email thing
with money coming out yes so that's
another approach rather than building a
story use this journey method and i10 I
recommend to use the journey method over
the story method when you're dealing
with really large bodies of data because
with the story method one disadvantage
is if you're missing one part of the
story the rest of it is gone right
you're missing a link in the chain there
basically so but with the journey method
because you're using locations from your
environment if you've committed to
memory a thousand pieces of information
if there were two locations you can't
see the images there you still have 998
pieces of information locked in your
memory so that's one advantage I would
recommend using the journey method if
it's really large bodies of data and
then wood that you're dealing with would
you say that as you use your living room
more
more that you get better and better at
placing objects in it and remembering
the path that you take and remembering
that information that's there that is an
advantage yeah but there there's an
advantage there but there's also a
disadvantage yeah you're going to become
much more fluid with using a journey the
more you use it but at the same time you
don't want to use one journey too much
because then you've got too many images
there and things start to get all all
jumbled together so you want to create
as many journeys as you can so I have I
have CEO clients that I work with all
over the country we do sessions over the
phone one hour a week over the phone it
works over the phone because of we're
just doing visual visual exercises right
these guys all started out with 25
locations from their office 25 locations
from their residents 25 from their
grocery store now they all have hundreds
of locations available you just need to
be systematic about it you know just 25
at a time you're a home you map out 25
look at ya 25 bars grocery stores gas
stations the key is being wrong you know
consistent and eventually you will have
hundreds of locations so at first
interested it sounds really daunting to
people but it's not that difficult to
believe it or not if you're consistent
in your training to eventually have
hundreds if not thousands of basically
mental filing cabinet storage places for
things that you would want to learn and
then this is just incredibly powerful
this is almost like a superpower that
you have you can in that you can use in
your life to really just commit to
memory anything right linking to visual
things together I'm linking both I live
in the mission so I'm linking the
mission theater with massive spinach
leaves growing out the top of it and
then I'm linking the the the burrito
shop that's right down the street with
me needing to make another business deal
and there's money though it's all
filling up with it so I'm linking these
visuals and then I can follow the same
path with different visuals the next
time
post-office gas station I mean that's
that's that's a really interesting
location so this is the story method and
the journey method based on loci loci
location the journey method is based on
locations yeah yeah yeah so okay so
here's some questions that I that I
usually ask people that come on the show
but I think that this one is especially
really close to you mimetics the
cultural transfer of information that
seems to be really growing to be super
important even more important in many
cases biological evolution takes a
backseat to cultural evolution until you
slower its way slower we pick up new
trends and new things that are happening
around us a change is so fast so with
the way that you're remembering
information what does that have to do
with mimetics with the cultural
information transfer well how did we
used to do it we used to do it by
stories right so everything was
transferred to the next generation
through storytelling yeah right so I
mean I guess that's how it's related in
that that is how it used to be done I
mean again just stories is a good way to
help people learn things new information
yes yeah and then this is something that
I think I've talked to you about in a
little bit of detail and I want to see
if we can address it again do you think
that practicing memory or encoding
things better using more of areas of our
brain visuals other senses do you think
that that potentially alleviates or
offsets the delays the onset of things
like Alzheimer's or other inner
generative diseases so what the research
shows right now is that there's no way
to prevent you from developing
Alzheimer's or another form of dementia
as of today no one has any idea how to
prevent it from happening if you're
destined to get it down the line but
what you will find a lot of research on
is this idea of cognitive reserve so if
people wanted to look up what I'm
talking about Google cognitive reserve
or otherwise look it up and this what
they think is that by engaging in
rigorous brain exercise so just
exercising your brain a lot in general
can help you build up this cognitive
reserve basically you can think of it as
being more brain muscle extra brain
muscle and if you do develop some form
of dementia down the line they think
that having this cognitive reserve can
make you more resistant to the disease
so in other words going to take more
years before the disease will start to
affect your everyday life so you can
gain some extra years of mental clarity
that you would not have had without that
reserve and one of the best ways they
say to build up a huge cognitive reserve
is by learning new languages because
that builds up so many extra connections
in in your brain but you know also cross
we rare in two languages yes you're
building so many extra connections in
your brain but even by doing you know
crossword puzzles and Sudoku I don't
know how to pronounce that word yeah
can that's good brain exercise so by
maybe right yeah chess is great mental
exercise brain exercise as well and
again this sort of memory training if
you stick to it is also going to be very
good brain exercise nowadays in some
treatment programs actually in addition
to giving patients that have some form
of dementia medication they actually
have them engage in brain exercise
programs as well to try and slow the
deterioration down but again it can't
prevent it from happening but it can
help delay possibly the onset of serious
you know the serious symptoms to where
it's really going to affect your your
everyday life so building of cognitive
reserves is crucial and we can yeah
there by actually practicing coding
information using different parts of our
brain
yeah learning lee this is definitely one
way to engage in rigorous brain exercise
but you can do a lot of other things as
well and other people will predict you
said perceive you as more intelligent
and you'll be able to climb up this
societal economic structure more more
quickly build friends that are building
impacting more people faster all that
good stuff it's really important really
just a little bit of a little bit of
extra preparation a little bit of effort
really goes a long way and really sets
you apart these sorts of I guess a lot
of times they would refer to this as
soft skills training maybe but those
little things really set you apart and
make you actually they it helps to make
you more memorable right compared to
other professionals that are just like
everyone else that are always looking
things up and don't have that
extraordinary memory ability yeah you're
nailing it again it's there's a little
bit of extra work will go a huge it
really way it really does and in that's
just right before you're going into your
meeting just review your notes try and
memorize the three most important things
add other visual add visuals to those at
different senses to those and you will
be a more outstanding for other people
and then they will become more memorable
that this is all really important and
really relatable I think
I think our audience is gonna really
like this and feel like put this stuff
to practice I mean - I got a lot of work
to do epic thing you want one one
example that I think everyone can relate
to where what I was just talking about
that little bit of effort goes a long
way as names yes so so many people out
there have just come to accept yet well
I'm not good at names and they have all
these ways to get around remembering
someone's name right hilarious graphic
that said that it was something along
the lines of as my problem is as soon as
I get introduced to someone I don't even
listen to it this hey yeah you know
people have just come to accept that as
their reality that they're just not good
with names and they find ways to get
around remembering people's names and
sure you can get around you know you can
get along fine going about your business
life you know your career in that way
but you're definitely not going to be as
impressive and you're really not taking
full advantage of the potential that's
there you can really build much better
relationships with people they can get
much more out of business networking if
you can make it a point to get better at
remembering names one profession that is
crystal clear in the power and this
politicians so I've actually been hired
by some politicians for private coaching
with me on just names alone because when
a politician attends a fundraiser they
want to know the name of everybody there
they want to know their spouses name
they want to know things they like
things they don't like so they know what
topics to bring up in conversation what
topics not to bring up in conversation
right that's massive politicians are
crystal clear on how this helps to make
you a more popular and more likeable
person in their case that will help them
to get more votes and more money for
their campaigns but you know in the case
of business professionals and
entrepreneurs this can help you to get
more out of business networking more
business maybe funding for your whatever
projects you're working on because it
helps you to build better relationships
with people you're more likeable a more
popular person and really it isn't so
much effort doesn't take that much
effort to really make a dramatic
improvement in your ability or member
names I'll quickly go over some some
steps so step number one and these are
even independent of the visual based
stuff so just these four steps I mean
anybody watching this should have no
problem putting this in a practice step
one
whenever you're introduced to someone
make it a point to immediately repeat
their name hi Chester and shake their
hand right so yeah exactly so nice to
meet you Alan I'm pleased to meet you
and it might seem obvious but a lot of
times as you mentioned when someone is
telling you their name you're paying no
attention at all to the name right so
step one forces you to pay attention for
one second that's the only way you could
repeat it back step two early on just
ask any question using the name so Alan
how do you know Chester Alan how long
have you been involved with this
organization just one question early on
reinforces the name step 3 think of a
connection between the name and anything
at all that you already know maybe Alan
its Alan Thicke it could be a famous
person an actor a character from a TV
show but it could also be something as
simple as you have a friend or family
member that has that same name think of
a connection between the name and really
anything at all that you already know
it's gonna help you remember the name
better and step 4 actually use the name
when you're saying goodbye so see you
later Alan or Alan it was great to meet
you hope to see you again sometime just
use it one time when you're leaving that
person that's gonna go a long way toward
helping you remember more names the next
time you see those people so those four
steps I think anybody should have no
problem putting that into practice and
that's going to help you to focus more
pay attention to names and and this is
huge in business it is its massive hi
hey Chester nice to meet you Chester how
long have you been practicing memory
Chester and chest and then things chess
they're great amici you know and just by
doing that you're totally right in
business above politician examples
really crazy important because that same
one same example applies to business the
more you know about your co-workers and
their spouses and the more that you know
about what their interests are
the more that you'll be able to get
along the more likeable you'll be all
that kind of stuff is directly
applicable again to business as well so
yeah this small thing is actually really
huge yeah it seems like something small
but it can give you a huge advantage and
again set you apart from other people
and make you more memorable with the
names I tend to focus on the positive
but there's also a big negative aspect
by not remembering people's names or
maybe even worse calling them by the
wrong name
especially if you do it you know I've
done it a few times already it really
can be detrimental and damaging to
business and personal relationships
that's actually the the main reason why
I quit my first job out of college I
worked at a law firm here in San
Francisco I'm not gonna say the name of
the firm but even after more than a year
of working there almost two years
actually there was still some attorneys
there that would call me the wrong name
and at one point I was absolutely
furious about it and it's the main
reason why I quit quit that job so this
can be also be very detrimental to
business and personal relationships and
some people are rewarded by the carrot
some people avoid the stick and this is
a Gary this is a good example of
avoiding the stick practice remembering
people's names so you don't have the
detrimental consequences associated with
them okay so we'll do a couple thoughts
to wrap it up I like how you talk about
spaced repetitions also very important
so when you do when you do hit those
three visualizations and you're adding
other senses to whatever you need to
remember for today again do it an hour
before do it two hours before do right
when you wake up do it a couple times
that day yeah so the idea here is spaced
repetition as opposed to many
repetitions done just the night before
cramming right so cramming that's how
most students would study that is good
for short-term memory only so you can
spit it out on the exam but then it's
vanished from your memory as opposed to
as it applies to students you might want
to review right
to the lecture maybe the end of the week
you know two weeks after a few weeks
after that I talked with exact
researchers at Washington University in
st. Louis about this they flew me out
there did some memory experiments on me
along with some jeopardy champions it
was something called the superior memory
project at Wash U in st. Louis and they
confirmed with their research that
spaced repetition is the ideal way to
lock things into long-term memory as
opposed to cramming yet from each other
there are different ways there are
actually apps out there that that are
built along this concept of spaced
repetition so the app will actually tell
you when you should probably do your
next review so this is a known concept
in in psychology as it applies to
learning space repetition is much better
than 20 repetitions done today at least
for long-term memory let's walk you
through a couple quickies on the
simulation list do you think what what
is consciousness do you think it's
centralized in the nervous system this
is not my area of expertise Ilana I was
worried about these simulation questions
or you just what is consciousness
I have no no good response I should have
like I should have asked to review these
last year what is consciousness
why don't you give me some theories and
I'll tell you which one I think I agree
with the most let's do it can we do it
that way
do you let's let's ask you the another
question associated with this is that's
a tough one
yes yeah do you think it's centralized
in the body or do you think it
potentially can live outside of the body
as well yeah I don't know that that is a
difficult question can it be both yeah I
think it can be both I mean I think that
it probably originates in the body but I
don't think that means it can't exist
outside of the body as well if you
Chester do you think that there is a
global ruling elite do I think that
there's a global ruling elite I think
there probably is I mean I again this is
not my area of expertise at all but you
know I've seen some you know some I've
read some stories and seen some videos
as to that effect basically the
Rothschilds for today supposedly they
rule on the central yeah so they really
have a lot of influence on every
actually every aspect of society I think
that may very well be the case and
should one endeavor to join the global
ruling elite to make a positive impact
on the world I don't think you need to
to make a positive impact on the world I
don't think you need to be at that
ruling level to really have an impact on
millions if not hundreds of millions of
lives how should we maximize human
potential
personal development is my you know as
my area of expertise that's what I focus
on on really mine is specifically memory
but I strongly and really before I won
the US memory championship before I got
into this as a career I was always
really into personal development and
that's what sparked my interest in the
US memory championship and really a big
part of why I'm doing what I'm doing now
is I really believe that we should try
to strive to make ourselves better and
whatever we're currently we can you know
if we learn the right strategies and put
in some training and practice we can
really improve ourselves and that's
going to help have a positive impact on
society right we're going to improve
society in general by improving
ourselves and you're you're gonna you're
gonna tell me right now that it's too
bad that I didn't remember it's like so
fun and I'm gonna look I haven't pulled
up right now yeah so safrussani is the
word safrussani is building up the
excellence of character until you become
a very well balanced individual and have
really strong self control and
temperance purity that kind of stuff so
safrussani I love I love your focus on
self development for maximized human
potential I think that's crucial and it
needs to be passed on from parents to
kids at a really young age yeah and then
it's accelerated by teachers in
community okay what's the most beautiful
thing in the world what is the most
beautiful thing in the world
whoa
now that you can go in many directions
with this huh let's say the human mind I
mean I I and that's I really think that
it is a an incredibly beautiful thing
the human mind I did it amazes me as I
travel all over the world giving these
presentations and seeing having the
privilege to experience so many unique
things on often times I'm just
absolutely amazed at what humans are
capable of things that we've created
things that we've come up with and but
this all originated from the human mind
right yeah yeah so just that little bit
of evolutionary advantage from a monkey
and then boom here we are making cool
things into the world in math I find
myself constantly being just blown away
by things that we've accomplished things
that humans have come up with it exactly
really amazing and then last couple is
are we alone in the cosmos you're asking
all these tough questions that are not
memory related or maybe they are I'm
just not used to answering them as being
a memory late that's what we like to do
we like to stretch really brilliant
people into new zones of I don't know
how brilliant III huh I don't know if I
would describe myself as a brilliant
person but I'm just really an expert in
the memory training you know
specifically the answer to that question
I personally believe that there is
there's all their life yeah I think
there is just because of the the
vastness of the universe I just I just
find it tough to believe that we're the
only yeah intelligent life out there and
then the last question is are we in a
computer simulation
I think that one's ridiculous to be
honest with you I see people you know I
know I'm not gonna say who but you
probably know who believes in that some
famous person but I I wa I just think
it's ridiculous No
so my answer is no definitely not
interestingly enough though don't your
answers contradict a little bit the
vastness of the cosmos and the vastness
of the universe and the intelligent
species are rising figuring out a call
and I stars and yeah figuring a fusion
can then maybe do something like quantum
compute our reality no I don't think
it's contradictory no awesome yeah
Chester this is an amazing I think you
know we have so many takeaways from this
but we got to practice the story method
the journey method we got a practice
figuring out how to add new senses
especially the visual sense into the
information we're trying to encode and
then recall later
Chester Santos has a great program on
his website international man of memory
calm and we're going to put the link in
the bio and definitely go check out the
six-hour yes six it's over six hours of
interactive training on names facts
figures exam material foreign language
vocabulary it covers many different
areas in in the online training and I
set up a discount code simulation to
give 60% off the course though guys 60%
off using the code simulation that's
really nice of you yeah awesome and then
you guys huge thanks for tuning in at
home if you guys had a good time please
you know Chester is also on Twitter at
what is your handle
Chester J Santos actually Chester jaesa
have a middle initial in there Chester
Jason and we're gonna put the link in
the bio as well to follow with follow
Chester and his work and his travel in
his impact that he's having across the
world right now I'm huge thanks for
tuning in if you guys had a good time
found this content useful definitely
give it a like give us a comment down
below give us a subscribe share it with
other people and then we have a whole
cool curriculum on patreon on patreon
patron if you find it useful get access
to conversations with guests get early
access to live events get access
exclusive content joined the community
and joined supporting us having these
great conversations of really smart
people like Chester and thank you Ron
Vargas for crushing up behind the
TriCaster and doing the directing and
producing Thank You River Studios for
having us here today and thanks Chester
greatly appreciate you thanks a lot
thanks for having me on yeah thank you
thank you
[Music]